[Music]
I'm a perfectionist I'm a person have to
work with my hands and it's what I know
it's what I love my passion how do I do
something and give it more function for
generations shoemakers in my family my
grandfather he was known for making the
best shoes I feel like it's really
important to have things that you can
take anywhere with you things that I can
travel with I'm Alejandro and these are
my 10 essentials this is organic Avenue
green juice and I'm obsessed with it and
it's healthy
this has kale a lot of other things
which I don't know what they are right
now but I just so it's green
this is paleo crunch and I have it with
me all the time it's this whole idea
that you eat like our ancestors did like
pavement on the Paleo diet you don't be
anything that has milk in it it's just a
healthier way of eating a lot of meat a
lot of nuts so this is almost like for
me like a Snickers bar this is the
Berlin backpack you don't want that
backpack that whew we're wearing in
school like that JanSport so it has that
backpack feel but it can be worn in
different ways it's it's where I use
it's what I go everywhere with what's
special about this jump rope it's a very
light I love it because I can travel
with wherever I go if I'm gonna tell
wherever there's an empty space I can
just you know do my cardio a jump rope
I'm known more for my sneaker so I
wanted something that was kind of simple
at the same time had a little bit of an
edge to it there's silhouettes very
simple but a little bit chunkier type of
sole
this is my lacrosse ball tension
reliever stress reliever my travel
massager this is a t-shirt from American
Apparel and I have five of them and
they're all in the same color and I love
it
either if it's the summer I just wear it
or layer it you know in the winter with
something else this is my iPhone and I
can't live without it and stay connected
to my business
which is really important this is
cellular repair cream and I like it
because it's very light and there's not
really any fragrance to it I wear
everyday just to take care of my skin
these shoes represent what's really
important in being in fashion you always
have to create the new but you also have
to have things that ground you and that
remind you why you do the things that
you do these shoes my grandfather made
in Cuba in the 1940s it's like something
that comes back to me and that feels
like home
so those are my ten essentials and it's
what helps me to get through life it was
great hanging out and thanks for
watching now I want to know about your
essentials leave a comment below
[Music]